hello and welcome to the first speaker
session in the law environment and
religion class at Yale University my
name is Hannah Malcolm and this is
Rebecca Loomis and we're delighted to be
joined this afternoon by James Anaya
professor of human rights and foreign
policy at the University of Arizona
College of Law and former united nations
special rapporteur on the Rights of
Indigenous Peoples dr. and aya you've
worked people groups all over the world
and all sorts of environments so it
seems that the identification of
indigenous is very complex in terms of
how you've come about defining it what
do you think are the key factors in your
work that have identified these diverse
groups as indigenous well it's really
not so much my work is the work of
groups themselves identifying as
indigenous over a period of time and
asserting claims link to that
identification as indigenous before
various forms and in particular at the
global level the United Nations forums
what I did is special repertoire of the
Rights of Indigenous Peoples was try to
identify the particular problems that
are common to groups identifying as
indigenous and addressed those under the
relevant international standards that
have been developing over the last 20 or
so years and that are now expressed most
prominently in the United Nations
declaration on the Rights of Indigenous
Peoples the declaration was adopted by
the UN General Assembly 2007 it does not
include a definition that identifies
which groups are indigenous but it is
clear from the instrument itself from
the declaration that is talking about
groups with certain histories of
colonization or something like
colonization that are the margins of
society assert identities that are
distinct from the populations that have
grown up around them and that want to
transmit those identities to future
generations and typically these groups
are linked to a particular land base
that they wish to continue to be linked
to so have any of those cases of
self-identification as indigenous being
particularly controversial or come on a
question or being the source of issues
when dealing with a bit
with a particular case yes but mostly in
the African and Asian regions where we
see government's contesting that
categorization as applicable to
particular groups there within the
American region meaning north central
South America it's rarely except that
the terminology of indigenous peoples
it's readily accepted that there are
groups that were whose I ancestry
predates in the region predates that of
the settler populations and that
maintain identities linked to those pre
settler groups within the region but
when we go outside of the American
region into Africa in particular you see
government saying things like well all
the people here are Africa or
everybody's non-indigenous all Africans
are indigenous except those few
relatively few settlers who remain after
the colonial period and so they can test
this idea that certain groups are more
indigenous than others similarly we see
that argument be made that in in Asia
but nonetheless we see we do see
discrete groups typically Minh numerical
minorities groups that are marginalized
again that maintain different identities
within the broader populations of those
those states and in Africa and in Asia
that identify indigenous and do and that
do share many of the same problems that
we see indigenous peoples experiencing
in the Americas and so that identity as
indigenous I do think in many respects
is apt for particular groups in the
African and Asian regions and
increasingly we see even governments in
those regions accepting the designation
of particular certain groups as as
indigenous so for example in the Congo
we see a new law having been passed in
recent years addressing specifically
indigenous peoples or using the French
term Pope popular so I talked on
obviously you see I don't speak French
what's something like that and I'm told
it means indigenous peoples and in the
Asian region increasingly see
government's opening up to addressing
particular groups under the rubric of
indigenous peoples and applying the
international standards that have
developed in that regard we could
mention Malaysia in particular where we
see an opening in that regard Indonesia
and the Philippines as well so we see an
evolution where there's ever more
acceptance of the terminology of
indigenous peoples not so much because
of some abstract determination that
there's some subset of humanity that a
prior is indigenous I think but more
because there's an understanding that
their particular groups that share
certain common set of problems that are
appropriately addressed under a common
rubric and the terminology of indigenous
peoples is a convenient one to do that
so in terms of the when you have this
issue of the framing of indigenous
people not being accepted by governments
say as you imagine in Africa and Asia
what what are the what are the basis
upon which an outsider can then support
their claim as indigenous because that
is not just a case of it being self self
identifying there have to be other
reasons and I was looking at some of the
basis for this identification that come
up in some of the UN reports so in the
Republic of Congo one of the ones which
is mentioned is that for example the
pygmies have a semi-nomadic way of life
all there are examples in the Jana jati
groups in the pool that they have this
history of subjugation as as a
particular thing so these seem to be
framing kind of categories that are used
beyond self-identification in order to
support a claim and say there are ones
which come up yeah or they do I mean the
one has to look at this more
functionally as opposed to in terms of
trying to come up with a definition and
then seeing a particular groups fit that
definition that's why I've tried tried
to do it and I in my in my work a
special opportunity
approach the definitional approach and
instead go straight to the problem that
it might be is being raised and then see
if that that problem was appropriate to
my mandate as the Special Rapporteur on
the Rights of Indigenous Peoples and in
doing so use a human rights framework
with understanding that human rights are
indeed universal and it's not the case
in my view I think one accepts the
concept of Human Rights it's not the
case that some groups have more human
rights at others what is the case of
some groups have suffered particular
kinds of violations in ways that other
haven't and so those groups deserves
particular kind of attention or need of
a particular kind of attention or a
particular kind of redress for for what
they've suffered and so like I was
indicating earlier indigenous peoples
have suffered particular kinds of
oppression with a particular kind of
common history that exists as as among
them or between them and yes these these
commonalities include the markers that
you indicated of oppression of
marginalization not so much being
nomadic because some groups are not you
know nomadic but the question is does
that characteristic of be nomadic
somehow disadvantage them is that link
to their distinct identity and are they
just had managed and then the question
is what to do about that not so much are
they then indigenous you see to me that
that that is the weather not their
indigenous simply helps us see the
relevance of standards and approaches
and mechanisms that existed to address
these common set of problems it doesn't
define their humanity doesn't define
their their essence it doesn't define
their rights in a fundamental way what
it does is it places these groups within
a certain category subset of humanity
with a certain set of common problems
and so I urge always taking I urge this
upon governments when they would resist
any kind of inquiry into a group into a
situation on the ground that these
groups aren't indigenous I would urge
elysees well let's put that aside for a
moment let's see what kind of issues
that we faced from a purely human rights
and then see if this categorization of
indigenous is useful or not and if it's
not well then let's not avoid the human
rights problem that that that we're
identifying let's proceed anyway to
address that and I actually found that a
useful approach and one that that was
disarming for some governments and
allowed me and or at least others within
the UN even right system to engage
governments can you give an example of
an instance where that was with India
you mentioned the yeah well perhaps you
did perhaps as a prior interview I've
been talking to number of people today
but in India that was a routine response
okay these groups are not indigenous in
India that all people who are indigenous
or the we've suffered our own colonial
history that's unique and and I would
address that say well you know you do
identify groups is tribal and that's
kind of close there are certain common
characters is your constitutional
in-laws talk about tribal peoples but
then I go try to go straight to the
issue at hand so in the in many of the
cases I looked at there were
mega-projects of the construction and
development of hydroelectric dams within
territories in particular groups that
we're presenting particular problems
resettlement forced resettlement
disruption of subsistence patterns for
example access to resources upon which
people dependent and so those those
problems were the ones that I tried to
focus attention on using the Human
Rights framework that I was charged to
promote including the framework as it
includes indigenous peoples to the
extent that those norms specific
concerning indigenous peoples were
relevant can you speak for a moment
about the role of religious identity
within that I'm just because you brought
up the example of India so for instance
the Naga tribal groups in the northeast
of India have in large part converted to
Christianity and that's one of the
reasons that the Indian government has
tried to deprive them of their scheduled
tribe yeah right so how do you how do
you see the role of indigenous
indigenous religions and kind of more
mainstream religions and
and instances of conversion changing
stations how does that plan well you
identify human rights problem i'm not
sure if it's the the categorization of
indigenous helps us in this particular
case because typically what we're
talking about when we're talking about
indigenous peoples are indigenous
peoples trying to maintain their own
religious traditions and the claim to do
that what you described or groups that
have changed religions as I understand
it yeah and I and our exit and are
insisting on the right to be able to do
that now but and I I think it's best
simply to approach it as human rights
issue as a matter of freedom of religion
and non-discrimination I don't know I'd
have to think about a little more I
don't know that the indigenous
categorization helps us that the by
saying that I'm not saying they have
have fewer rights than indigenous
peoples to the contrary I'm saying that
they have the same rights but it's this
categorization in this in the context
that you've identified is it really
helpful so that actually illustrates
what I'm trying to say yeah I kind of
want to tease out the M the approach
that you take when you you want to
approach it from a human rights
standpoint you want to say that
indigenous people groups are allowed to
have and should be given the same rights
as other groups of the reason you have a
special emphasis on them is because they
haven't been afforded those rights but
how do you bring that to the table if
you're dealing for instance with a
government or an agency which is framing
them as particularly indigenous so like
ending in the example of India they are
given certain they're given certain
benefits by the government because they
have this indigenous identity tribal
identity tribal identity yes so how do
you then frame it because I mean if they
then just have human rights in India
that means they would lose their
benefits if they lose that indigenous
identity it is a distinguish between
human rights are universal and based on
certain concepts to particular rights
that servers might have in a domestic
legislation and and and those may have
to do with human rights but they may
have to do a certain arrangements they
may have to do certain ranges that might
not be very acceptable and we have in
many countries laws that you know system
of apartheid right for granted
different rights to different groups
based on their racial status and and
assign them particular territories and
you know the the South African and
Namibian government said that those are
in fact privileges preme provided these
distinct groups when in fact the rest of
the world looked at that system
apartheid is highly discriminatory and
damaging to those groups oh so there we
have an extreme example of domestic
legal systems that recognizes distinct
rights or status entitles to diverse
that groups with it doesn't have much to
do with the International Human Rights
framework in fact is in tension with it
and I think that some aspects of India's
internal all regarded scheduled tribes
can be criticized on that ground as well
it's not i'm not saying it's a system of
apartheid but i am saying that it's not
the same as as he is that the same as
applying the human rights framework to
these diverse groups that are identified
as scheduled tribes and so that's really
a different kind of situation analysis
all together I think okay so would you
consider the priority in in framing your
approach to be largely to do with
protecting their autonomy on the
particular land or area that they again
I the frame of reference are those
standards that are developed within this
particular category of indigenous
peoples that respond to a particular set
of problems and those standards are
today most notably articulated in the UN
declaration on the Rights of Indigenous
Peoples and so in my work is Special
Rapporteur and I let's dress very soon
because you know I'm also just teach
basic human rights and do other things
but I think that's you're talking about
I would use that as the main frame of
reference and essentially if an issue
didn't fall within what the Declaration
speaks to I I would consider it not
within my jurisdiction as you could say
the Declaration does focus on the
collective rights of groups that that
collective dimension to the exercise of
Human Rights for example language you
know it's you can look at language from
an individual right standpoint but it's
not really a complete assessment of that
right
that you don't take into context the
group because unless you think that you
know talking to yourself as a meaningful
exercise of the right two languages I
don't think most people do so you're
taking to count that group context
self-governance right the writer
self-governance also includes political
participation but one needs to take an
account the fact indigenous peoples
historically continue have their own
institutions of self-governance and
that's part so so affirming their right
universal human rights of political
participation in a decision make it
affects an easy to take into account
those institutions that that organic to
them and also often require specific
arrangements for them because of their
their difference in order for them to
generally participate effectively Emma
and in the decision-making governance
governance decision-making that affects
the lands and resources because of the
problems that have been that indigenous
peoples have faced the deprivation of
their their connection with with lands
and resources or their traditional lands
the declaration speaks to that and
affirms that big eNOS peoples are
entitled to maintain those connections
to their traditional lands and resources
as a matter of their human right to
property as well as a human right to
culture because cultures and their
cultural survival is linked to those
lands and resources and often as as part
of their right to religion because often
these territories are characteristically
there there's there's a sacred dimension
to the two places that that are
important to the survival and existence
of distinct groups and so these are the
kinds of issues do is the declaration
the declaration addresses that again
relate to these common sets of
scotland's common problems that
experiences that is in the experience of
indigenous peoples that relates to
common histories as well and not all
groups who have experienced these and so
while all groups have the same basic
human rights equality property property
political participation culture you go
down the line of the basic principles
they play themselves out differently
with regard to indigenous peoples
because of their particular context
their historical context and the
realities today and the collective
dimension of these rights becomes very
important and the remedial aspect of the
human rights imperative becomes very
important because it's not simply about
allowing sitting back and allowing
groups or distinct peoples to exercise
rights that they've been exercising all
wrong all along it's about addressing
those historical deprivation of the
rights for these particular groups and
the contemporary manifestations of those
historical deprivation okay we'd like to
shift the conversation slightly to focus
more on environmental and land access
issues you briefly touched upon the
importance of access to land associate
traditional lands but i was i was
wondering more specifically whether
having a certain relationship with the
environment factors into the identity
for some of the indigenous groups that
you've worked with certainly but i
wouldn't overplay that and you maybe
have gotten that from from my writing I
I think that all of humanity has a
relationship with the environment I
think that what we see with indigenous
peoples that knowledge about the
relationship with the environment and
and life human life is much more present
for a variety of reasons but I don't
think it's necessarily a characteristic
unique to indigenous peoples or groups
identified as indigenous as opposed to
two others it is an important component
of indigenous peoples demands today to
have their environments respect to have
a natural environment respected and have
their relationship with the natural
environment respected in ways that allow
them to continue that relationship that
they've had with lands and resources and
so for many indigenous groups of course
their ways of life and their access
traditional lands have
and severely disrupted or harmed by
colonialism and other forces and does
does the environment or land access play
a key role in the goal of achieving
reconciliation yes absolutely the demand
as I said of indigenous peoples to their
lands relates a good bit to the natural
environment of maintaining the natural
environment in a state that is such that
they were able to continue to to benefit
from the lands and resources that have
sustained them over time or to regain
connections with lands and resources and
reestablish the those subsistence
patterns that historically have
sustained them but it's also about about
a maintaining or reacquiring a cultural
space the land basis is that spatial
element of culture for indigenous
peoples is what allows them to exercise
the various dimensions of their lives
that constitute them as a distinct
culture so that land base having that
land basis is important for that and yes
very often the the environmental aspect
is very much important to that as well
but then it's not necessarily the case
that indigenous peoples aspire to
maintain the natural environment in a
pristine state and dizziness peoples
like others strive very often to benefit
to the resources materially in a way
that's consistent with maintaining their
resources as a land base that's
essential to the continuation of their
cultures and so increasingly we even see
the development initiatives buying these
people themselves once they were able to
to secure control over lands and
resources we see development initiatives
by them running in to loggerheads or
tensions with or resulting in tensions
with environmental groups those who
would want to
tane the land area pristine or we see
initiatives say by major conservation
organization the world conservation
organizations that whole conservation
organizations that operate on the on the
world global level and governments to
establish protected areas national parks
these kinds of things we see those
initiatives creating tensions with
indigenous peoples often these
organizations are very surprised oh why
they don't want this us to establish
this pristine national park where they
live so that they can continue to live
like they always have their very
surprised when the indigenous people say
well you didn't talk to us about that
now you're limiting our ability to
develop way we want to on these
resources that are ours and but the but
these organizations are learning I think
and these initiatives are becoming more
sensitive to indigenous peoples own
aspirations for development but but but
it is something that we're seeing more
and more of as indigenous peoples more
and more claim of voice and decision
making that affects them we're seeing
more of these tensions arise where
environmental groups or conservation
groups want to set up a conservation
area National Park something like that
and indigenous peoples resist that or at
least question it those initiatives
because they're not adequately a part of
those initiatives have tensions between
indigenous groups and environmentalists
perhaps because of a divergence of
interests factored into your cat all of
you if any absolutely yeah I looked at
ahead a number when I was special
reparatur I looked at a number of these
cases where we saw national parks being
set up particularly Africa where you
know the indigenous groups or groups
whatever you want to call them that are
I said live in areas where these
protected zones are being established or
these national parks be established
haven't historically had a voice
and and so we vowed that that more and
more attention is being given to their
particular interesting concerns and they
are acquiring more of a voice in the
National Arena and even an international
arena you're seeing more and more that
they're expressing concern in opposition
to the creation of these conservation
areas in the traditional territories
unless they're part of the process for
creating them unless they are actual
beneficiaries in a real sense from what
these particular areas may bring and
unless their own aspirations for
development are accommodated in the
establishment of these areas it's not
that that the indigenous people's
interests are at odds necessarily not
certainly it's not the case that they're
always at odds with conservation
initiatives I think that that for the
most part they they they are but it's
the lack of participation and the
establishment of these these protected
areas in these conservation zones that
raises a concern and that indigenous
peoples then question or the basis for
their questioning of these of these
initiatives do you think this so it
sounds like environmentalists maybe are
coming to more of an understanding that
indigenous groups do you know have
motivations when it comes to
conservation areas and they're not
simply they don't think we share the
interests of environmentalists and and
do you think this sort of has arisen or
can be furthered through more of
individual advocacy or connective legal
mechanisms and what's a way to improve
improve this relationship or improve
environmentalists knowledge and
awareness of I think things you know I
environment us become more sensitive to
indigenous peoples distinct interests
but I think really the ultimate solution
is for there to be a an awareness by
environmental groups that they really
have distinct interests not necessarily
opposing interest but they're distinct
and they need to just step aside in my
view from indigenous peoples own sphere
of activism
and their own articulation of their
aspirations and demands we see too much
of a forced alliance by environmental
groups with indigenous peoples
particularly in the developing world
when where these peoples don't have
their own independent financial means
for advocacy or they don't have other
allies and so at particular points in a
controversy over resources for example
there might be a very natural and
strategic alliance forged between
environmental groups indigenous people
say opposing an oil develop project that
is causing devastation in an indigenous
territory it's of course in the
interests of indigenous peoples to stop
that because it's polluting the waters
and the soils and the natural habitat
that they live from or want to live from
and environmentalists are of course they
live to oppose such they exist to oppose
such polluting or devastating
development projects that we see all too
often or I've seen all too often in
various parts of the world of the that
are the result of oil and gas
development but then at the time when
say we were at a place where where there
are new possibilities for development
that aren't as polluting or of the same
character as what what indigenous
peoples have experienced before and
indigenous peoples may want to entertain
some development and their territories
including oil development
environmentalist groups can be very much
in the way of indigenous peoples
exploring and pursuing the options that
they might
they certainly are entitled to explore
and pursue as a matter of their own self
determination I like to say that
indigenous peoples just like anybody
else can have the right to make mistakes
have the right to choose own path for
development that that may in fact be
path that aren't entirely in sync with
other people's conception of what is
correct but unless they have that right
they really don't have the right to
self-determination they simply have the
right to make choices that those from
the outside particular environmental
groups think are correct it seems that
we have them these two categories that
were using here of things being sacred
and protected in terms of in terms of
this dialogues going on between
environmentalist groups and indigenous
peoples I was wondering if you could
speak to that relationship between the
sacred and the land from an indigenous
peoples perspective when they're when
they're stating their right to the lands
and is it the case that the land itself
is viewed as sacred and how does that
tie into the practices being carried out
on the land of sacred and the
relationship it seems that a lot of the
partnership confusion that happens with
environmentalist groups is that they
assume that indigenous people groups
will see the land the same way they do
that it should be left right to a
greater degree as possible in the
condition that it was found and so in
order for that not to be the way the
news people groups think there must be
another understanding of what it means
to that land to be sacred to them I was
18 yeah well you can't it's impossible
to generalize and it's on the one hand
it's different for different groups this
notion of what is sacred and how that
relates to the land and therefore this
within the same groups you have certain
areas that may be sacred another's that
aren't or certain or maybe the whole
area may be considered at some level
sacred but that doesn't mean it can't be
developed you know of
the mountain could be sacred but so
could the minerals within it in a as
used in a particular way and so the
sacred mountain gives the minerals for
the minerals to be used in a sacred way
and I'm not revealing any particular
attribute of any particular group but
I'm just giving an example a
hypothetical one really because it is a
complex matter and I I I just think it's
important to understand that that
something being sacred doesn't
necessarily mean it cannot be used in
fact it's a good call quality could be
come from its utility in in many ways
like the end the animal lives you know
the in many many cultures animals are
hunted they're killed and that it is a
sacred act it where's for the
environmentalist vegetarian that's like
really terrible you know and it's often
hard to understand how how that can can
be a sound way of going about life
killing an animal and then eating it and
much less to understand how that could
be sacred so it you know there it's it's
a complex matter one cannot generalize
about about these things do you think
there's a point then of which that runs
out is there a point at which one of
those discussions we were having in this
class and when we were talking about
this issue was whether there can be a
point of which a government or outside
agency can say the way that this
indigenous people group have used as
land is it's not appropriate they've
they like those are a point in which the
utility runs out I know that that's very
tied into previous problems of canola
anism plenty ism and oppression but yeah
we there's this question of at what
point is that right to the land
exhausted
as it were well we're mostly in most
contexts were not there because
indigenous peoples don't have secure
rights to begin with so that's that
would be a good problem to have i think
where you have the jews people's really
control their lands saying well we're
going to put a coal plant here because
we want to and then the state regulator
coming to say wait a minute we have to
regulate that that that's I think that's
a good problem to have who are having in
that debate where indigenous peoples are
in control and develop the resources and
and our place where the outside will say
wait a minute we let's we have an
interest too because what you're doing
is having externalities that that that
that generates a concern on our part we
need to do then come to terms on what
you're doing and how it affects our our
lives I I happen to think that yeah
there is a space for that dialogue I
mean if you have certain people who take
the view that of absolute indigenous
sovereignty you know I don't think there
is any absolute sovereignty on the part
of any segment of humanity in the part
of governments our state's themselves
independent states they grow in a world
that we all have to live together
somehow and I think that if indigenous
peoples have how to say in the
construction of the governance
institutions around them and that
there's some kind of agreement or
acquiescence that they by which we can
say that they are genuinely part of the
broader governance institutions
including those of the state itself then
the state does have a legitimate
interest and claim to regulating to some
extent what happens within indigenous
territories to the extent what happens
there affects some elsewhere this is an
attack this is not an entirely academic
debate you have for example tribes in
the in the western United States at
times wanting to store radioactive waste
and clearly there's a concern of the
porta surrounding communities about that
and I think rightly so and the national
government in this case the federal
gov'ment has has an interest in
regulating that and the tribes have have
an interest in coming to terms of the
broader society through the federal
government about about that as well
it seems that establishing property
rights may be an effective tool for
enforcing the rights of different people
to landed resources through land titling
for example and I was wondering whether
you proceed there to be any
disadvantages culturally or otherwise to
setting up those types of property
structures ideally there'd be this this
respect for it and indigenous peoples
customary land tenure patterns without
having to have those those land tenure
patterns specifically identified and
registered but that that isn't practical
in today's world or practicable in
today's world given the competition over
our lands resources that it needs to be
some kind of identification of who owns
in a sense what and where to where one's
rights to extend and what the character
of those those rights is and it's the
registration or titling processor in
many caches the demarcation process by
which that is achieved and so I think on
balance the these mechanisms for
specifically identifying indigenous
people's lands and the types of rites
they have within those territories or
the or the rights they have beyond those
areas where they have exclusive
ownership or something like excellent or
ownership that that that's necessary on
balance and we're seeing thus a number
of initiatives across the world to do
just that to title lands or to demarcate
them and secure them in favor of
indigenous peoples now the disadvantage
is it tends to freeze in time processes
there that may not have been frozen or
in time or that aren't frozen that is
where indigenous peoples have have
migrated over time or their land use
areas of have expanded or are contracted
or have developed in certain ways over
time to use certain kinds of resources
and those are natural patterns but it's
difficult to sustain those when you have
competition over over areas and and
particularly difficult when that
competition results in in degradation of
the resources and so there's a need to
have some overarching regulatory
framework that that tries to ensure
against the degradation of the resources
for the benefit of everybody while
securing the rights for for all the
legitimate rights of all concerned
including indigenous peoples so sort of
going broader to your career with the
United Nations we know that you are the
special rapporteur on the Rights of
Indigenous Peoples in a drafter of the
UN declaration on the Rights of
Indigenous Peoples um and I was
wondering what you perceive to be the
most effective tools the United Nations
has in order to assert the human rights
of indigenous peoples well first of all
you sort of aggrandized wife of my
contributions I really have a career I
was a had an appointment for eight for
six years and it should be understood
this position of Special Rapporteur and
right from the Guinness people's is is
one that is outside of the bureaucracy
of the UN it's or it's a sort of sweet
generous status the UN is made up of
member states of course and they're
represented by diplomats and the various
functional bodies in the united nations
such as the commission excuse me the
Human Rights Council which used to be
the Commission on Human Rights dance the
Human Rights Council is made up of of
governments and then you have the
bureaucracy which is that permanent
staff that services the initiatives of
the united nations that are set in
motion by the Member States and then you
have these so-called independent experts
that are appointed by the governments in
this case in my case by the Human Rights
Council to work in certain areas but
we're appointed to be independent from
everybody including the bureaucracy so
even though the bureaucracy assists
these in appendix burst so I had you
know people within the
offsite Commissioner of Human Rights
helping me and even though I was
appointed by the government's the Human
Rights Council I presumably and I think
I did was to operate on an independent
basis not taking instructions from the
government or from the bureaucracy and
to give an independent assessment of
what I what I saw and so I just I just
wonder that the they clarified that what
what position I had and within the
United Nations it wasn't a staff
position or a career position by any
means it was a limited appointment for
two consecutive terms and that that did
give me a perspective on the question
that you raised uh what can the UN do
and I came out of it thinking not much
honestly um and what it could do it
isn't doing enough of Oh what it is good
and i should say it's not doing enough
of i think what the UN can can really
contribute in this area that is
promoting the rights of indigenous
peoples and what it's not doing that
file is awareness-raising about one the
problems that indigenous peoples face in
a global level what we had we see is
this sort of international elite that
includes certain government
representatives independent experts that
are connected with the UN system
non-government organizations and a cadre
of indigenous representatives that go to
international meetings that are aware of
indigenous issues but that hasn't
penetrated in to the system as such that
is the UN system and when that an
operational level it very broadly anyway
in my dealings around the world with
different countries in different
countries i should say i would also deal
with not just government representatives
all those countries but also with you
nations representatives in those
countries the UN has a presence and a
lot of developing countries if not most
and I would often in most cases that I
would visit when I visit a country I'd
deal with them and I was astounded to
see the lack of awareness of the UN
operatives in those countries about the
presence of indigenous peoples the
issues they faced or the standards that
were to be applied to promoted so it's
it's even within the UN system there
isn't sufficient awareness within
government bureaucracies there's
insufficient awareness beyond those
diplomats who go to the UN meetings the
concern indigenous peoples they are very
well versed in the international
standards their declaration the issues
they know what to say but at the country
level at the operational level the
awareness of indigenous issues the
standards that apply to them is
extremely thin to non-existent not to
mention that the societal level I i I'm
quite sure that most people in New Haven
don't know anything about the native
people just historically lived in this
area or that still do the issues that
they face to how it is that they came to
naught P around as much as they used to
be and what the result of that
displacement displacement has been the
same for where I live in the
southwestern United States you know
we're surrounded Tucson Arizona is
surrounded by it living indigenous
communities yet the majority of the
population is completely oblivious to
their presence and what that means and
so awareness-raising within society as
well so at all within the UN system
within government and within societies
it needs to be greater awareness and
with that education about what the
challenges are that indigenous peoples
face and the kind of initiatives that
need to be put in place and with that
awareness is greater sensitivity the
political class responds more which is
which is extremely important and these
issues then not only can be addressed
but can be many of the
problems that arise can be avoided
entirely and the UN has a can your
question of what can he even do it
contribute to that process much better
than it does now what does it do instead
it appoints one special reporter to
cover the whole world to go around
looking at problems and reporting back
and it establishes a permanent for
indigenous issues gives them two weeks
we're going to come together and talk
about whatever they want to honor the
Guinness issues and you know everybody
go to me some media goes it's not the
mainstream media goes and you know like
to take pictures of the indigenous
people in their traditional dress and
all colorful and everybody comes you
know fuzzy card and feeling good about
it people are there but then across the
street in manhattan no one's really
aware what's happening you know across
the sea at the end it no one really is
cares you know what's happening they
they care to the extent that that they
might find some pleasure of seeing
indigenous people walk around the
streets of midtown in the traditional
dress but you know that it's it's very
much a something that doesn't penetrate
into the broader society that met that
presence of indigenous peoples at the
United Nations in New York once a year
and so a lot of energy is devote being
devoted to to sort of re rehashing
what's already been talked about within
the UN system and not enough energy to
targeted initiatives to raising
awareness and expanding education and
problem-solving on the ground and I
think the UN system has a lot could
contribute a lot more in that way it
seems that you're um you're raising this
question essentially of reconciliation
between indigenous peoples and those who
are non indigenous peoples in the same
area how you how you bring them into
conversation in terms of awareness
raising how do you go about that without
just creating a different form of
distance where you have the kind of
awareness raising like when children in
school learn about indigenous people
Bruce but it's a different group of
people that are not
like them who live in a reservation they
have their own and there is an actual
communication between the two groups
that doesn't seem like societal
reconciliation to me it seems just it
seems like further education normally
about history rather than current events
how do you go about awareness that leads
to reconciliation yeah well you stated
the problem right I understand as soon
as you do is not not saying what what
what should be happening but what what
might already be happening and what
contributes to the problem the this
distancing haven't against people
because the extent they are taught about
in schools it's about something in the
past something about that they you know
as opposed to part of the we and that
that contributes to this lack of
societal wariness lack of societal
awareness about indigenous peoples and
their issues today by reinforcing that
notion that they are distant in
something of the past and typically with
that distance in an historical
perspective there's a denigration of
indigenous peoples they're viewed as
something that was in the way of
development something maybe at best
curious you know the noble savage but
you know some Nobles I was destined to
pass to pass away because the inability
to survive in the modern world I mean
that that's the attitude that we see
prevailing that within the educational
system to the extent indigenous peoples
at least in this country are treated
within the educational system how how to
get away with out how to get around that
i'm actually not entirely sure how to do
that i just know that's not not the way
to do it if I just think of my own areas
of the area of law and legal education I
I can can think of various ways in which
which we can incorporate the legal the
curriculum of legal education awareness
of indigenous peoples and not just the
problems that were were
were imposed upon them but also the
contributions that they made you know we
have an hour we teach property for
example in law schools and issues having
to do with the original habitants are
very much or should be very much part of
our instructional property how did this
property system develop around
indigenous territories to begin with I
think in most property law books there's
one case and that basically says well
they were conquered and that's it and
that's it there's that there's nothing
more than that when I fact it's much
more complex than that and you know when
what about all this territory that today
is under the genus control how does that
figure within our property system within
our study of federal public lands and
public lands more generally natural
resources more generally these issues
can be incorporated constitutional law
is rich in issues having to do with
indigenous peoples would typically
aren't treated within your typical
Constitution law class in my own work on
international law and international
human rights i've incorporated issues
concerning indigenous peoples but not
just say okay today we're going to study
indigenous peoples and then tomorrow
we're going to move on to something else
but rather to incorporate these very
cross-cutting issues that we've been
talking about today throughout the
course issues of collective rights
equity what is equality mean in
different contexts reconciliation
reparations I mean all all these issues
can be looked at now with attention to
the the contributions that indigenous
peoples have made and so we could do
that at all levels of education and one
way or another from primary education
the secondary education university
education and if we talk about policy
making on the part of politics certainly
there's there's there's something to be
said for including indigenous voices
within that policy making much more so
that is that is done today what I found
when I would engage governments was that
I would ask about indigenous issues for
example with with health departments or
health ministries and there's oh well
that's the indigenous Department over
there I said what do you mean you know
what about how do you treat the
particular problems faced in between
indigenous communities face or do you
incorporate traditional practices
healing practices in your outreach for
in health / in developing and promoting
health programs these kind of issues I
try to raise with with the mainstream
ministries and and and and that I think
is where we get start to get more
awareness raising the kind of education
that's needed and then ultimately the
implementation of these standards that
in principle have been agreed upon by
this sort of Club that I mentioned
earlier these the regulars the usual
suspects among government actors
non-government of actors and urine
bureaucrats that are in this world of
indigenous rights and we all know each
other it's like them you can put us all
in one room really not much bigger than
that so yeah someone bigger than this I
mean it's lucky you know who the
government represent is going to be that
you go meeting across the across the
globe it's the same government
representative and they say the same
thing which is completely at odds with
what their government do the same NGOs
you know this is showing up saying the
same thing and the same so-called
experts saying the same thing and you
know today I'm the special repertory
tomorrow I'm a professor from someplace
saying the same thing you know showing
up being invited the same meeting to say
the same thing and it's is this is
really kind of insta group it does it
isn't penetrating much but it makes a
lot of noise and so then you have a
class at Yale talking about this stuff
you know yeah I mean we have time for
one more question so in terms of that
last question in this classroom you have
law students and divinity students and a
forestry school students how would you
like to see this group of in some way
you know this kind of strange Ivy League
small group how can we be part of
infiltrating that gap between knowledge
and awareness and reconciliation that is
a
the big question powerful what I would
turn the question around no given what
we've talked about how could each of you
see yourself I don't want to use it will
contribute at least being a participant
and in some way and moving forward and
and seeing Human Rights enjoyed more
universally and enjoyed by groups that
have suffered particularly disadvantage
i think that's that's something we each
need to ask ourselves and see how we can
do that in whatever specific role we
take on in our professional lives or our
lives of students or otherwise it's not
a matter of santo cab i am today going
to become an indigenous advocate and i'm
going to go out there like a missionary
and start doing that you know devote my
life to it you know I have the calling
and so I'm going it's it's about that
awareness and I think I I stressed
taking it on being sensitive to it and
whatever you do apply that sensitivity
in a constructive way great thank you
very much
you